قبل نحو 100 عام فقط كان يعتقد ان مجره
درب التبانه لا يتجاوز عرضها بضعه الاف من
السنوات الضوئيه كان معظم الناس يعتقدون
انها تمثل الكون باكمله في القرن السابع
عشر كان عالم الفلك الفرنسي شارل ميسي يعد
قائمه بالاجسام غير النجميه حين رصد عددا
من الاجسام الضبابيه الغامضه في السماء
ولم يعرف وقتها انها مجرات اخرى وفي
ديسمبر من عام 1924 اعلن عالم الفلك
الامريكي ادوين هابل ان السديم الضبابي او
الغازي اندروميدا هو في الواقع مجره اخرى
وان درب التبانه ما هو الا مجره وسط
العديد من المجرات في الكون اكتشف هابل
عشرات المجرات قبل انتهاء العشرينيات من
القرن الماضي وقدم اول نظره ثاقبه لاصل
الكون اطلقت ناس اسمه على تلسكوبها
الفضائي الذي دخل الخدمه عام 19
90 اما جيمس ويب خليفه تلسكوب هابل الذي
يستكشف البدايات الاولى لنشاه الكون وبصور
عاليه الدقه حقق العديد من الانجازات
الفلكيه المذهله منذ اغلاق اطلاقه عام
2021 اهمها اول صوره ملونه للفضاء والاكثر
تفصيلا على الاطلاق لنشاه الكون